the state with the most people is making
the newest recreational marijuana legal
hundreds of Californians lined up on New
Year's Day to buy some though pot is not
yet available throughout the state muta
a vol is at a medical marijuana
dispensary in West Hollywood
that begins recreational sales today
mirre oh good morning good morning out
of the more than four hundred businesses
in California licensed to sell adult use
marijuana only about a quarter of them
are actually selling it right now
AHS WeHo where we are standing this
morning is one of them at its owners
actually told me like many in California
they've been gearing up for this
historic moment for several years now
with the cutting of a green ribbon
Harborside dispensary oakland kicked off
legal sales of recreational marijuana
Monday Henry Wieckowski was the first in
line to be able to now just walk in show
your driver's license and make a
purchase it's been a long time coming
the milestone which allows anyone 21
years of age and older to buy a
possessed recreational pot comes nearly
two decades after California became the
first state to legalize medicinal
marijuana lines popped up at
dispensaries with customers ranging from
longtime users to first-time buyers the
only thing I'm really surprised by was
the number of people my age I thought I
was gonna be the only grandfather first
rate as well as the ratio this is
absolutely going to be a recreational
habit for me I could just smoke the
quarter of a blunt have some heat hose
and I'll be good but not everyone's a
fan about a dozen California towns have
reportedly banned recreational sales
altogether and law enforcement is
concerned about a potential rise in drug
driving as has been the case in other
states like Colorado in Washington we
fully expect to see an increase in
crashes due to marijuana usage experts
believe the new industry will generate
billions of dollars for the state
bringing an estimated 1 billion dollars
a year in tax revenue alone I think it's
really important that we have to end the
stay
around marijuana I'm an employed
functioning adult and I also smoke weed
and I don't think there's anything wrong
with that
now that the doors are open here in
California more than 1 in 5 Americans
live in states where recreational
marijuana can legally be purchased
however the federal government still
views this as an illegal controlled
substance comparable to heroin and LSD
Alix media thanks